back here on the show not only to talk
uh with us
uh about life and what's going on in the
nba playoffs but he
has a directorial debut he co-wrote the
film
and he stars in it as well it's called
domino
battle of the bones available in select
theaters this friday
he is baron davis how are you baron
what's happening
what's going on never too late it's
never too late what to to
to rap for you and get in the studio i
mean
if that was four years ago you know you
didn't reach
back out to like the pandemic oh okay so
we
no there's there's no no it's also a
very los angeles thing baron you've been
around here a very long time to say that
you're gonna invite someone to do
something on their project and then
never do it
i'm a man of my word we got the studio
it's nice and built out okay
it's even bigger now you know i'm gonna
do it in bars
we're gonna get you right that means i
was wrong
it's basically what you're also saying i
was initially wrong
yeah i mean you know you're not wrong
you know there are no wrong
answers because you put forth the effort
let's talk about a movie you're
directing huh this is
this is fantastic when when did you uh
shoot this you snoop is in it david
arquette you're in it
this is great yeah uh i would say
probably a year after
i did that uh my last show with you
so two years ago okay um
and shouted in the summer pre pandemic
uh
and really wanted to like write
something with
uh comedians you know uh
that showed like this casual life of of
this game of dominoes but
also reflected on some of the characters
that you know i witnessed growing up
that you know i felt were funny and
you know i i'm always trying to extend
my creative palette
and so i had an investor you know put up
the money for me to direct my first
feature
and she said i believe you can be a
director and so from that point
you know for me i just started writing
the script and working on this movie
and now we just got a photograph of
snoop in it too
that so that was an easy uh ask for you
right baron
imagine getting snoop involved
oh do i just move do we just lose baron
davis you there baron
yeah okay dad just lose you you there
yeah i think uh uh sorry about that okay
it's all good
so uh you got snoop involved in this as
well
that's what i said it was kind of
probably a nice easy ask for you to say
hey snoop how'd you like to be in my
movie
right yeah it was i mean you know
surprisingly we could we you know we
can't afford snoop
so it was like hey oh man can i get a
favor
and he was like yeah nephew i got you
don't need a trip you got 45 minutes
and i was like i'm shooting the movies
like hey all right 40 minutes
i was like uh you know i only need you
you know for a day or two it was like
all right 30 minutes
and i was like all right he was like you
can come now
it all worked out though that's
phenomenal and it worked out
and he did it in one take basically once
two takes he was done
right um where does this rank in terms
of degree of difficulty for anything
you've attempted in your life
physical athletic or not
i mean it ranks up there i would say uh
you know i i i don't know i mean this is
this was fun this is a fun project
i think that sort of like being a rookie
and like okay this is my first one
you know i'm more excited about now that
i have that
behind and it's out like i'm ready for
the next one because
you you just learn so much and by
and you have so much more confidence and
you know how to better prepare
uh you know for the next one so i'm
looking forward to the next one
and you know i've been writing a couple
things so
you know i'm super excited about just
this next chapter because it is a lot
different from the nba
where the nba you can control your
destiny but
in a situation like this you know you
got to rely on so many other people and
you know hollywood to be able to
shepherd that in
it's called domino battle of the bones
about a competitive domino player from
compton
uh i've got the log line here
reluctantly agrees to babysit his white
nerdy step-grandson but he discovers a
kid's crazy skills and then off they go
to try and play some dominoes
baron davis here on the rich eisen show
uh pretty cool to have steph curry shout
you out as he did
uh because of your warriors team
the we believe team kind of 2.0
by the current warriors this year that
had to be cool for you baron
right no that was super cool uh you know
any time the warriors shot us out
i always say you know it's just keeping
us alive in the game of basketball steph
curry
one of his biggest fans and you know
just always respecting him and his craft
and
you know what he's able what he has been
able to do you know
at golden state and you know the seal
kind of
you know give me love you know what i
mean it is huge
and you know i just i mean i mean that's
what i do it for that's
that's what i wanted to do it for i
wanted to be able to be a players player
some someone that when i walk in the
room you know the players wanted to
talk to be around you know and just gain
that respect so
you know uh anytime you know
there's any kind of like reflection in
that in that spirit of energy
you know it just it just completely
humbles you is there any player that you
used to play
with or or against that
luca doncic remind you of at all
uh they remind me of
he just reminded a lot of different
people
he reminds you of like brandon roy as
big as brandon roy was
he remind you of sam he remind you
of like um a little
magic you know what i mean he reminds
you a little bit
of uh i would say like a
like a not like a jaws in petrovic
you like you see you just like he he's a
one-on-one
there's there's it
it's hard to
like you can see so many different moves
and so many different
you can tell he's a student of the game
and so
you know i i always say you know when
people ask me that question is that
you know start looking at these
ballplayers as artists
right and so you know really it's hard
to compare
someone who's a you know an original
painter to
others that have been original painters
in their own format
and uh what advice baron davis would you
give to um
damien lillard right now as uh the only
professional
basketball coach he's known is now out
um and the question is can he win
in portland one of the most talented
dynamic
players in the game what advice would
you give him if uh
you were sitting down with him today
baron davis
uh man i mean damien is a man
you know i would say for me it would
just be
to be a listener you know what i mean so
it's hard to give
advice to somebody that you have not
listened to
and seen their perspective or you know
hear
you know what they're going through you
can only kind of like look at the
situation and and kind of judge and say
yo i've been in that situation before
but my situation it that i reflect on it
is much different and you know
danielle's situation so
you know before kind of giving advice
it's just better to be a listener
you know what i'm saying no i hear you
so i guess let me let me just walk in
it's just the nature of the business you
know it's the nature of the business
like
you know like this is now an opportunity
for him to
you know do something else play a
different way
you know what i mean you know uh take on
a bigger challenge right
uh you know he he has performed well
uh with with terry stouts and i think
that
you know he's really you know just
really like
continues to maximize his potential
right but i also feel like you know
there's an opportunity with whoever the
new coach is and hopefully they make the
new
the new and the right coaching decision
that they can take his game to a whole
nother level and so
you know i would just say um
it really depends on the coach right but
i think for damn just be
which i know it is it's what does this
new coach
you know see that that that i can
improve on
right to up my auntie and uh my game do
you think he can win in portland
i guess i'll just walk through the front
door on this one with you
you do i do i do i think you know uh
for portland it's really about you know
putting putting and assembling the right
pieces together right you know that's
the team that
every year they've had a different set
of wing players
right and backup point guards and things
that you know you may
you know a lot of people may not value
but it's super valuable
um you know and i also feel like they've
been
you know they've had some injuries to
their young guys which support them
but overall it's like they have talent
and
you know there they're a couple pieces
away i think and
and they have an opportunity right you
know you look at the west this year
there's going to be
you know somebody new coming out
challenging it's going to be somebody
uh new coming out the east so you know
the league is
starting to get you know a lot a lot
more uh competitive
um and i think portland could have been
one of those teams that we've been
yeah i guess you know the question is is
can you it does seem that the
once again the the league
you know despite avi obviously seen what
the heat did
last year making it to the finals and
kawhi
doing what he did in port i mean in
toronto it still does seem to be
you've got to team up with a superstar
type league we're seeing the nets
even without harden be so terrific in
game one
and you know because they have durant
and kyrie
and that maybe when it all comes out in
the wash giannis
getting all that help from this
offseason it's still not enough because
he doesn't have another superstar to
team up with him like kawhi does with
uh paul george potentially you know i
know it's not cookie cutter but
it does seem that if you want to win a
championship you've got to get somebody
to ride along with you and and maybe
lillard can't get that in portland
that's the that's the genuine
conversation about
about the opportunity that he has baron
you know
okay i'll hear you but you still believe
he can win there in portland okay
um you know and and look
i always come from like this old school
mentality i was always like
had to play the david to goliath you
know what i mean
so i never had the privilege of playing
you know
on a you know superstar driven team
you know so um
but now that's the nature of the
business right that's the way things go
um but maybe portland can get somebody
in there
that can be that person or or that
potential superstar
i hope so because i i love damien
literally i love his game before i let
you go baron of the final eight
who's got the best chance to win it is
it the nets right now
what do you think i like you know right
now i like the unlike the nets
i like the clippers and i and i wouldn't
uh count out the signs
just because devin booker is probably
one of the hardest
people to guard uh that we've seen it a
lot
and then of course you got the jazz too
we'll see how it all works out and i
love the jazz
i love i love i love that they just
continue to fly under the radar
right yeah for one seed too right yeah
that's you know that's what you want
they're playing great basketball
and they're winning and they have you
know they have they have a lot of great
pieces
and i love queen snyder i think he's a
great coach
well baron it's been great catching up
with you let's do this more than just uh
once every uh
two years or so let's uh help me out so
i love to like you know come in every
three or four
episodes and you know i can do like the
uh
weather report you know i
i could do something like i can i can
read out the ads
i can drop in some of my own promos okay
um
you know it's like a brother up man
i i'd love it baron like we're we're my
movie
watch my movie domino battle of the
bones we'll do that that's going to be
available
the app okay there's a domino battle of
the ball
that download that okay and then you and
i will
will develop this back our relationship
yes please
um over a game above let's let's do that
um
i would love to do every last thing that
you just said
there's no question um it's it's not a
me thing it's got to be an us
thing is what i'm saying you know what i
mean let's do it okay let's do it
look for my call look for my call you
take care of yourself that's baron davis
everybody battle the domino battle of
bones is available on an app
go forward and then also in select
theaters this friday
june the 11th the one and only baron
davis hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here